on va parler sport et tourisme
maintenant à l'approche des Jeux
Olympiques évidemment évidemment on en
parle de plus en plus les gios 2024 se
dérouleront entre le 26 juillet et le 11
août et déjà les acteurs du tourisme se
préparent à une très très haute saison
c'est le cas par exemple des loueurs de
Git et des hôtels si pour le moment pas
question de s'emballer l'ffetgio n'est
qu'un scénario tous savent cependant que
la région peut compter sur sa proximité
avec la capitale euh sa proximité avec
la capitale pardon et la volonté des
touristes de prolonger leur séjour en
France alors comment se prépare-t-on à
cet afflux massif dans nos
établissements la réponse avec Clémence
Dosque situé à seulement 1 heure en
train de Paris l'indrloire envisage
plusieurs scénaris de fréquentation pour
sa saison estivale dans le viseur les
Jeux Olympiques 2024 et les 16 millions
de touristes attendu dans la capitale
mais c'est pas une base arrière en fait
c'est juste le château de la Loire ça
c'est une première chose donc là on est
sur les visiteurs étrangers puis un
deuxième effet qu'on peut sur lequel on
peut escomter euh c'est euh l'afflux de
visiteurs franciliens qui vont venir se
mettre un petit peu au vert pendant la
durée des jeux des Jeux Olympiques à
Paris deux profils de visiteurs se
dessinent d'un côté les étrangers qui
pourraient prolonger leur séjours de
l'autre les Franciliens qui souhaitent
s'éloigner de la capitale voire de
soulouslouer leur logement selon UFC Que
Choisir les prix de certaines locations
parisiennes ont déjà augmenté de 200 %
sur la période des jeux mais pour les
professionnels de Touren pas question de
s'adonner à cette pratique V de France
nous on propose des vacances familiales
avec des tarifs familiaux l'idée c'est
absolument pas de céder à cette hystérie
collective tarifaire surtout pas donc on
restera sur une tarification qui qui
sera qui suivra une hausse normale telle
qu'on peut l'imaginer d'une année sur
l'autre rien d'autre en septembre
dernier l'effet Coupe du monde de rugby
n'a pas ramené la vague verte escomptée
sans parler d'un déferlement de
touristes étrangers ou de Franciliens la
Touren compte bien tirer son épingle du
jeu l'été prochain